liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
an diesem dienstag zu einer
pressekonferenz zum thema corona kurz
vorher zwei sätze zur erläuterung für
diejenigen die uns auch live verfolgen
in zeiten der korona pandemie die
bundespressekonferenz ist eine
regierungsunabhängige organisation von
journalistinnen und journalisten die aus
der hauptstadt über bundespolitik
berichten wir wissen um das große
interesse an informationen in dieser
pandemie und haben daher in diesem jahr
auch weiter als sonst die live
übertragungen der veranstaltung in bier
erlaubt wir bedanken uns beim
fernsehsender phoenix dafür dass ja eine
gebärdensprachdolmetscherin zur
verfügung stellt die auch dort zu sehen
ist das übernehmen heute daniel meixner
und bernadette peterka herzlichen dank
dafür
heute begrüßen wir zum thema coroner
lage vor weihnachten rechts neben mir
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
daneben den präsident des robert koch
instituts professor lothar wieler und
daneben die direktorin des instituts für
medizinische virologie am
universitätsklinikum frankfurt sandra
zeck und auch der von mir aus gesehen
linken seite die vorsitzende des
deutschen ethikrats an den airbags
herzlich willkommen
in dieser reihenfolge werden wir kurze
eingang statements hören bevor wir zu
ihren fragen kommen und sie herr sparen
beginnen bitte liebe frau burschen meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren wir sind
es gewohnt dass sich in der woche vor
weihnachten die dinge der alltag das was
noch zu tun ist die aufgaben oft
verdichten wir nennen das
vorweihnachtsstress das erleben wir
gerade wieder aber ganz anders als uns
die ministerpräsidenten haben sich am
wochenende mit der bundesregierung
geeinigt das öffentliche leben in
deutschland weiter herunterzufahren ab
morgen in den kliniken und pflegeheimen
kämpfen pflegekräfte und ärztliches
personal um die gesundheit und zu oft
auch ums überleben ihrer patientinnen
und patienten und der pflegebedürftigen
und in den bundesländern bereiten sich
alle mit hochdruck darauf vor
auch tatsächlich mit dem impfen so weit
ein impfstoff da ist beginnen zu können
der schotter und meine damen und herren
war geboten
lieber jetzt mit aussicht auf erfolg als
erst nach weihnachten mit dem risiko
großer nebenwirkungen
wir müssen selbstkritisch sagen es ist
uns zwar gelungen die infektionswelle zu
brechen aber die infektionszahlen sind
weiterhin viel zu hoch und besonders
auch die todeszahlen vor allem in der
gruppe der hochbetagten so lange wie
möglich haben wir die balance gehalten
beschränkung von privaten kontakten
einschränkungen vor allem auch im
bereich von freizeit von gastronomie
kunst und kultur ja aber die kinder
sollten weiterhin die kita und in die
schule gehen können und die wirtschaft
sollte so weit es geht weiter laufen
können
diese balance war angesichts der zahlen
und der entwicklungen der letzten tage
und wochen nicht mehr zu halten wir
haben gesehen dass sich eine dritte
welle praktisch schon wieder begannen
aufzubauen bevor die zweite tatsächlich
abgeflaut waren
wir mussten daher vor weihnachten das
klare signal setzen dieser jahreswechsel
muss anders aussehen als üblich wichtig
ist nun dass das vereinbarte auch
umgesetzt wird in allen regionen des
landes in allen bereichen und auch
konsequent umgesetzt wird
ich weiß das wird hart für viele in den
nächsten wochen für diejenigen die sich
auch auf weihnachten und den
jahreswechsel gefreut haben nach einem
jahr mit viel verzicht und entbehrung
aber vor allem auch für diejenigen die
am corona virus erkrankt sind oder sich
um erkrankte kümmern
auch eine vollbremsung wird eine lange
bremsspur haben auch das finde ich es
wichtig jetzt schon auch zu sagen und zu
erkennen allerdings haben wir hoffnung
auf besserung
es gibt im stoffe die schutz versprechen
und deswegen setzen wir alles daran dass
dieser impfstoff so bald wie möglich
zugelassen wird und ich will da ist
angesichts der aktuellen diskussion ganz
kurz erläutern die zwei ansätze haben
von anfang an gesagt wir machen keine
not zulassungen sondern eine ordentliche
zulassung weil es darum geht
vertrauen in das impfen grad in dieser
pandemie auch bestmöglich zu gewinnen
und zu erhalten und die frage wie ein
impfstoff zugelassen wird ist aus meiner
sicht doch etwas was vertrauen erweckt
und deswegen gibt es eine ordentliche
zulassung durch die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde eben auch um dieses
vertrauen zu erhalten und zu gewinnen
und zweitens haben wir von anfang an
gesagt wir machen das europäisch nicht
national wir haben europäisch gemeinsam
beschafft uns im stoffe gesichert und
vorbestellt gemeinsam investiert in
produktion und den forschung bei den
unternehmen und wir machen auch
gemeinsam nun die zulassung dass wir
stärker als das ich das gilt im kleinen
in der gesellschaft miteinander in
dieser pandemie
das gilt aber eben auch in großen in
europa und innerhalb der europäischen
union und ich wunder mich schon über
manche tonlage dieser tage wir reden
viel über europa und europäischen geist
und dann in der krise dann wenn es
tatsächlich drauf ankommt ziehen einige
zuerst brutal die nationale karte es
geht darum europäisch gemeinsam diesen
weg jetzt auch weiter zu gehen denn das
schafft eben dann auch gemeinsam
innerhalb europas und untereinander
vertrauen
gleichwohl wir wollen eine gründliche
prüfung eine ordentliche zulassung und
gleichzeitig eine zügige prüfung unserer
nationalen behörden unterstützen
bestmöglich wie andere auch die
europäischen behörden ziel ist eine
zulassung noch vor weihnachten zu
erreichen
zum jahreswechsel wollen wir in
deutschland mit dem impfen beginnen noch
vor dem jahreswechsel
genau genommen nicht am jahreswechsel
sondern beides möglich nach der
zulassung die rückmeldung aus den
bundesländern machen mich zuversichtlich
dass das klappt wir haben mit den
bundesländern vereinbart dass ab dem 15
ab heute wieder einsatzbereit sein
wollten und auch sein werden so dass es
dann zügig los ging eine damen und
herren dieses jahr hat uns viel
abverlangt dieses jahr hat auch gezeigt
wie widerstandsfähig wir sind unser
gesundheitssystem unsere wirtschaft vor
allem wir
als gesellschaft es hat uns gezeigt wenn
wir uns unter stress vertrauen wenn wir
auf uns und unsere stärken vertrauen
dann können wir einen unterschied machen
wir haben uns gegen dieses virus
gestemmt wir haben gezeigt dass wir in
der pandemie diesem virus nicht wehrlos
ausgeliefert sind und wir sind zusammen
geblieben die überwiegende mehrheit hat
sich solidarisch verhalten hat
aufeinander achtgeben und tut dies auch
weiterhin und es gilt weiterhin genau
dafür dankeschön zu sagen es braucht
nämlich beides entschlossene staatliches
handeln und bürgerlicher
eigenverantwortung ja meine damen und
herren die lage ist so ernst wie sie
noch nie war in dieser pandemie die
fallzahlen sind insgesamt zu hoch wie
nie und sie steigen weiter an
die gefahr besteht dass sie die
situation weiter verschlimmert und es
damit immer schwieriger wird mit der
partie in ihren folgen umzugehen
seit beginn der pandemie bis heute
wurden dem robert koch institut
insgesamt rund 1,35 millionen kubik
fälle übermittelt
wir schätzen dass etwas mehr als eine
million menschen die akute infektion
überstanden haben und 22 1475 menschen
sind an oder mit diesem virus verstorben
bislang wurden im dezember pro tag
zwischen 12 und 29 1000 neue fälle als
erker übermittelt das sind deutlich mehr
als noch im november
wir sehen dass das infektionsgeschehen
in den letzten tagen praktisch in allen
bundesländern zugenommen hat auch wenn
es natürlich unterschiede zwischen
einzelnen bundesländern gibt aus sachsen
übrigens wurden für den gestrigen tag
keine fallzahlen übermittelt in der
letzten woche haben wir aus sachsen
immer so um die 1909 infektionen pro tag
übermittelt bekommen
diese fälle werden wahrscheinlich heute
nachgetragen das heißt also wir
berichten dann morgen wahrscheinlich
rund doppelt so viele fälle aus sachsen
das hat eine technische hintergrund das
virus ist in der gesamten bevölkerung
verbreitet es kommt in allen
altersgruppen vor
aktuell sind über 325.000 menschen in
deutschland mit saas kopf 2 infiziert
die sogenannten aktiven fälle
zur erinnerung in den sommermonaten
waren das wenige tausend
nur und immer stärker betroffen ist die
altersgruppe der über 80-jährigen das
sind leider auch diejenigen menschen die
ein sehr hohes risiko haben schwer zu
erkranken oder zu versterben und wir
sehen auch leider immer mehr ausbrüche
in alters- und pflegeheim diese
entwicklung hatten wir befürchtet wenn
das virus erst einmal breit in der
bevölkerung zirkuliert dann wird es
immer schwieriger die wilde rabe in
gruppen zu schützen
das virus zum beispiel aus den heimen
herauszuhalten
aber auch die zahl der kogit 19
patienten die intensivmedizinisch
behandelt werden müssen steigt mit stand
gestern 4670 patienten auch das meine
damen und herren ist ein bisheriger
höchststand und parallel dazu sinken
natürlich dann auch die freien
kapazitäten auf den intensivstationen
immer weiter nach den zahlen des die wie
intensiv register vor allem gestern
bundesweit von insgesamt rund 27.000
intensiv plätzen etwa 22.000 gelegt und
leider sterben hierzulande auch immer
mehr menschen ankurbelt 19
allein für gestern wurden im
robert-koch-institut und 500 neue
todesfälle übermittelt
wenn wir uns das mal anschauen in der
letzten wochen in woche 43 das war die
woche mit der ende oktober starben rund
380 menschen in der woche 48
das war ende november sind bereits mehr
als 2300 menschen verstorben gemeldet
worden und letzte woche die woche 50
waren es mehr als 1800 wir müssen aber
davon ausgehen dass diese zahl noch
deutlich steigt denn todesfälle wären
noch lange nach gemeldet von schweren
verläufen todesfällen sind in erster
linie ältere menschen betroffen
aber nicht ausschließlich wir fahren
unabhängig von den todesfällen auch
zunehmend über langzeitfolgen der
infektion bei mitmenschen und zwar in
allen altersgruppen
sie finden alle diese zahlen im
situationsbericht den wir täglich auf
unserer website publizieren und der kljb
und dienstag ist der bericht besonders
ausführlich und die anderen zahlen die
aktuellen finden sie natürlich auch auf
dem dashboard und der korona punkte
de wie gesagt heute fehlen doch die
zahlen aus sachsen man damit keinen
moment infizieren sich viel zu viele
menschen mit sauerstoff 2 was wir
zurzeit sehen ist das ergebnis der
sorglosigkeit einiger menschen für die
andere menschen wiederum einen sehr
hohen preis zahlen müssen von den
ausbrüchen heimen und den todesfällen
hatte ich gerade berichtet beides nimmt
weiter zu die gesundheitsämter sind
zunehmend erschöpft sie schaffen es zum
beispiel nicht mehr kontaktperson zu
ermitteln oder das infektions umfeld zu
klären
viele krankenhäuser kommen an ihre
belastungsgrenze ärztinnen ärzte das
pflegepersonal arbeiten am limit
wir können müssen alle dazu beitragen
dass das infektionsgeschehen wieder
besser unter kontrolle kommt und zwar
sofort
die meisten von ihnen und von uns tun
das bereits und wir alle tun sehr viel
um das virus einzudämmen
nun legen wir gemeinsam noch einmal
einen drauf und binden auch jene ein die
zu sorglos waren die neuinfektionen
müssen jetzt deutlich sinken
wir haben aktuell einen höchststand an
infizierten und weil schwere verläufe
und todesfälle immer erst mit einem
gewissen zeitverzug eintreten müssen wir
uns darauf einstellen dass sich die
situation über die weihnachten auch noch
zuspitzen wird
daher mein ganz klarer appell an uns
alle
schenken wir unsere kontakte auf das
nötigste ein wegen wir ab was wirklich
uns wichtig ist ich werde die
beschlossene höchstzahl der über
weihnachten möglich kontakte sicher
nicht ausnutzen
ich bleibe ganz bewusst darunter um
meine kontakte auf das allernötigste
einzuschränken
und ich appelliere an alle ärzte ärztin
das medizinische fachpersonal halten sie
durch und setzten sie auch die
empfehlungen des robert koch instituts
und dann alle schulen nutzen sie die
kommenden schulfreien wochen um sich auf
die zeit danach vorzubereiten damit der
schulbetrieb hoffentlich im januar
wieder sicher aufgenommen werden kann
setzen sie die umfangreichen
empfehlungen des robert koch instituts
direktes wort ja sehr geehrte damen und
herren sie erwarten jetzt bestimmt dass
ich ihnen als virologin etwas zum bios
oder seine ausbreitung erzähle und ja
ich könnte jetzt viele zahlen ich könnte
vergleiche mit flugzeugen machen ich
könnte über die langzeitfolgen berichten
ich möchte ihnen aber lieber von einem
telefonat berichten dass ich am
wochenende mit einem alten freund und
kollegen geführt habe er arbeitet seit
vielen jahren als arzt auf einer
intensivstation anderen großen uniklinik
irgendwo in deutschland und einem haus
der sogenannten super maximalversorgung
es ist also sehr gut ausgestattet neben
der hohen arbeitsbelastung berichtet er
von pflegemangel betten sperrungen und
zunehmende frustration und ich muss dazu
sagen mein freund des intensivmediziner
aus leidenschaft aber was frustriert ihn
erstens die krankheit selbst frustriert
ihn die bittere erkenntnis dass man den
patienten oder den patienten medizinisch
nur sehr eingeschränkt helfen kann
außerdem das personal nur wenig zeit
sich auszuruhen oder mal luft zu holen
und die versorgung von schwerkranken co
at 19 patienten ist körperlich extrem
anstrengend und mental sehr belastend
zweitens er ist frustriert weil er die
übernahme von schwerkranken aus anderen
kleineren krankenhäusern die nicht so
gut ausgestattet sind ablehnen muss weil
er keine betten hat kein pflegepersonal
obwohl er weiß dass diese patienten
wahrscheinlich bei ihnen optimal betreut
werden könnten durch die belegung der
betten mit 19 patienten können auch
andere schwerkranke nicht bestmöglich
versorgt werden operationen müssen
ausfallen und verschoben werden
und insgesamt werden also auch viele
patienten die keinen korb haben deutlich
schlechter versorgt drittens bestimmte
menschen frustrierenden oft fragt sich
das krankenhauspersonal warum die
schuften müssen warum sie sich selbst
gefährden müssen nur weil andere sich
nicht zusammenreißen können
hinzu kommt der aspekt der gefühl
schwindenden wertschätzung der
gesellschaft im frühjahr gab es auch
klaus vorbeikommen und aufmerksamkeiten
für die krankenhausmitarbeiter das hat
erheblich abgenommen
dabei ist die situation jetzt viel
angespannter als im frühjahr war
können sie sich vorstellen wie man sich
fühlt wenn man täglich sterben die
patienten betreut
oder wie groß die angst sein muss diese
krankheit selbst zu bekommen
nach hause in die familie zu nehmen und
was bitte soll man dann denken wenn
gleichzeitig immer noch menschen auf den
straßen corinna leugnen und diejenigen
beschimpften die sich an die regeln
halten
jetzt fragen sich vielleicht warum ich
von diesem telefonat erzählt habe ganz
einfach ich möchte ihren blick auf etwas
lenken dass ich persönlich schwierig
finde es heißt in der öffentlichkeit
immer dass wir dann noch gut mit der
pandemie zurechtkommen wenn es noch
genügend freie betten auf den
intensivstationen gibt dann sei alles
gut aber diese perspektive ist wie ich
finde äußerst zynisch sie verkennt
nämlich die tatsächliche situation der
dort behandelten patientinnen und
patienten die um ihr leben kämpfen und
doch sterben oder die zwei aus der
klinik entlassen werden aber noch monate
an den folgen leiden und würden wir so
weitermachen wie bisher gebe es einen
schrittweisen kollaps unseres
gesundheitssystems bereits jetzt gibt es
in vielen kliniken probleme weil
pflegende und ärzte selbst erkranken
auch an coop 19
wir können dürfen nicht akzeptieren dass
täglich viele hundert menschen in
deutschland sterben und noch viel mehr
menschen langfristige zum teil
lebenslange folgeschäden haben werden es
gibt aber auch eine gute nachricht wir
müssen es auch gar nicht akzeptieren wir
sind teil dieser pandemie und wir
verbreiten das virus liegt es an jedem
einzelnen von uns diese zahlen zu
reduzieren
dieses jahr habe ich deshalb einen
großen wunsch bitte feiern sie
weihnachten und silvester anders
minimieren sie die kontakte und auf das
nötigste und schützen sie damit sich und
ihre liebsten schenken sie es uns und
allen mitarbeiterinnen im
gesundheitssystem
mein freund wird übrigens dieses jahr
weihnachten nicht seine eltern besuchen
er hat sorge dass er sie anstecken
könnte weil er für uns alle jeden tag
mit 19 patienten versorgt und er muss
verzichten
vielen dank danke frau brooke ja meine
damen und herren ich begrüße sie ich
habe die dankbare aufgabe nach diesen
statements über etwas grundsätzlich sehr
positives und erfreuliches zu sprechen
nämlich über die impfung und dem beginn
der impfkampagne der beginn einer echten
exit strategie aus dieser pandemie
das beruhigt das gibt hoffnung das ist
eine echte mensch heizleistung das
und dieser weg wie möglich ist aber wie
das in dieser pandemie so der fall ist
gibt es auch hier herausforderungen
das ist mit vielen dingen so und so auch
hier zunächst gibt es nicht genug
impfstoff für alle und wenn nicht alle
die das gern möchten anfangs impfstoff
bekommen können dann erfordert das eine
priorisierung also eine bevorzugende
abfolge in der geimpft wird bis genug
für alle da ist durch eine solche
priorisierung sollen die impfdosen
möglichst gerecht verteilt werden
möglichst gerecht weil es eben bei
echter knappheit keine situation gibt in
der man allen das geben kann was sie
gern möchten
ich glaube es ist inzwischen gerade auch
nach den debatten in den letzten tagen
allen klar dass es hier wirklich ums
eingemachte geht eine solche
priorisierung berührt elementare fragen
ethische rechtliche das gesundheits
league und lebensschutzes jedes
einzelnen aber auch der gerechtigkeit
und solidarität in der gesellschaft
und deswegen kann sich eine solche
priorisierung nicht nur aus
medizinischen und empirischen daten
ableiten sondern sie muss auch auf den
ethischen und rechtlichen grundsätzen
die in unserem land gelten aufbauen
ich betone dass deswegen so deutlich
weil deutschland eines der wenigen
länder weltweit ist in denen explizit
und transparent die ethischen aspekte
mit bedacht und vorausschauend als teil
der impfstrategie ausgearbeitet wurden
wenn sie mir dieses wort des lobes
erlauben wollen gemeinsam mit der stiko
und der mit der ständigen impfkommission
und der nationalen akademie der
wissenschaften leopoldina hat der
deutsche ethikrat dazu im november ein
positionspapier veröffentlicht in dem
der recht ethische rahmen entwickelt
wurde
die stiko setzt diese nun in ihrer
feinkörnigen priorisierung um und ich
danke allen die an diesem prozess
beteiligt waren
die prinzipien wie diese arbeit zugrunde
liegen sind die selbstbestimmung die
nicht schädigung beziehungsweise der
integrations schutz gerechtigkeit und
grundlegende rechtsgleichheit
solidarität dringlichkeit die schlagen
sich nieder in vielen verhinderung
schwerer verläufe und todesfälle schutz
von personen mit besonders
arbeitsbedingten saß kopf zwei
exposition risiko verhinderung von
transmission und aufrechterhaltung
staatliche funktionen des öffentlichen
lebens das einzige 3 also die
verhinderung der übertragung können wir
jetzt noch nicht sicher an steuern da
fehlen uns noch erkenntnisse zur
sogenannten sterilisieren immunität also
dem sicheren ausschluss von übertragung
aber insbesondere im ziel 1 und auch
zwei und vier können wir an steuern
aus ethischer perspektive und unter
berücksichtigung dieser rechts ethischen
prinzipien ergibt sich also dass man
folgende gruppen vorrangig priorisieren
sollte erstens menschen mit signifikant
erhöhten risiko für schweren oder
tödlichen verlauf zweitens
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im
gesundheitswesen die aufgrund
berufsspezifische kontakte ein erhöhtes
risiko haben oder die als
multiplikatoren das virus in
einrichtungen hinein und in andere
bereiche der gesellschaft hinaus tragen
können und drittens personen oder
gruppen die in basalen bereichen der
daseinsvorsorge und für die
aufrechterhaltung zentraler staatlicher
funktion eine schlüsselstellung besitzen
das sind sehr viele unterschiedliche
gruppen gesundheits mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeitern gesundheitsämtern
lehrerinnen und erzieherinnen polizei
sicherheitsbehörden feuerwerk und so
weiter dazu noch einige kurze
erklärungen eine solche priorisierung
unter knappheit kann nur im rahmen einer
zentralen impfkampagne umgesetzt werden
mit impfzentren beziehungsweise
aufsuchenden mobilen impft teams danach
kann man dann wie gewohnt in die
niedergelassenen praxen gehen ganz
wichtig auch und oft missverstanden
diese prioritäten sind nicht sich
ausschließende prioritäten dh es muss
nicht gewartet werden bis die eine
gruppe komplett durch geimpft ist
sondern man kann zumindest die ersten
gruppen parallel impfen da es
unterschiedliche geschwindigkeiten und
auch praktische herausforderungen geben
wird menschen im pflegeheim die mit den
allerhöchsten risiken können meist nicht
den impfzentren kommen sondern sie
müssen auch suchend geimpft werden
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter im
gesundheitswesen können meist direkt in
ihren einrichtungen geimpft werden
die ständige impfkommission hat nun die
relevanten empirischen daten und die
literatur systematisch gesichtet und
aufbauend auf diesen vorgaben eine
genauere priorisierung entwickelt noch
steht die endgültige impfempfehlung
aussiehst in den letzten zügen aber aus
dem entwurf den sich ja viele gesehen
haben ist zumindest sichtbar dass diese
vorgaben umgesetzt wurden
und so treffen sich hier tatsächlich
ethische rahmen überlegungen empirische
daten und auch der common sense es gibt
befragungen in der bevölkerung die eine
überwältigende unterstützung für diese
priorisierung nachzeichnen eine solche
situation hat man eher selten dass ich
das alles trifft und das ist erfreulich
wichtig ist nun dass diese vorgaben
nicht in stein gemeißelt sind sondern
laufend angepasst werden wenn neue
impfstoffe kommen oder sich die
kenntnisse erweitern etwa mit blick auf
sterilisieren der immunität und lassen
sie mich abschließend noch einen letzten
satz sozusagen ins unreine dazu sagen ob
diejenigen die jetzt am anfang vorrangig
geimpft werden irgendwelche sonderrechte
erhalten sollen oder sich anders als der
rest der bevölkerung verhalten dürfen
das ist aus ethischer perspektive nicht
sinnvoll
erstens wissen wir wie gesagt noch gar
nicht sicher dass die impfung wirklich
die übertragung verhindern also die
infektion von anderen
zweitens werden wir noch eine ganze zeit
große gemeinsame anstrengungen gegen die
pandemie brauchen abstatten und
nasenschutz hygiene lüften corona vanek
usw
und drittens wären sonderrechte auch mit
blick auf die vorgegangenen ethischen
überlegungen problematisch wir alle
stehen jetzt als gemeinschaft für
diejenigen zurück die besonderen schutz
brauchen und sich besonderen risiken
aussetzen und wir lassen deswegen diese
gruppen wohlbegründet vor im gegenzug
wäre es dann unausgewogen wenn diese
menschen vorrechte erhielten während
sich alle anderen noch gemeinsam gegen
die pandemie stemmen vielen dank
danke dafür dann kommen wir zu ihren
fragen vielleicht eher zwei bitten
stellen sie sich kurz vor und sagen sie
am besten auch an wen die frage geht das
gilt auch für die kolleginnen und
kollegen die uns digital fragen zuwenden
und an zu senden und dann die noch
zusätzlich der hinweis wenn sie nicht
dazu schreiben wer sie sind und werde
frage stellt kann ich die hier leider
nicht berücksichtigen und ich beginne
auch mit einer frage die uns online
erreicht hat von philips kopien rtl und
n tv an den gesundheitsminister
wie bewerten sie die jetzt wohl
gemeldete impfstoff zulassung durch die
emea zum 23 dezember und inwiefern ist
es für sie wichtig mit jedem tag früher
der impfstoff zulassung mögliche
todesfälle vermeiden
das ist eine gute nachricht dass eine
zulassung am 23 12
mit stand heute also wenn die daten die
er jetzt weiter bearbeitet werden dass
auch hergeben aber man darf die miss
tisch sein
eine zulassung am 23 12 erfolgen kann
das ist eine gute nachricht für die
ganze europäische union weil wir
natürlich sehr zügig anschließend
gemeinsam mit dem unternehmen in die
verteilung kommen innerhalb der
europäischen union ich sage noch einmal
einer der gründe warum wir das zusammen
gemacht haben war auch dass alle 27
mitgliedstaaten
gleichzeitig ist nicht auf die stunde
genau aber doch eben jetzt dann nach der
zulassung beginnen können zu impfen und
ich werde mir sehr sicher deutschland
frankreich italien niederlande die etwas
vielleicht wohlhabenderen staaten oder
auch die größeren staaten hätten das
auch alleine gekonnt frühzeitig aber es
wäre nicht für alle 27 gewesen das ist
ein solidarisches gemeinsam seien in
dieser situation und wie gesagt wir
haben in den letzten tagen auch mit
unseren nationalen behörde dem
paul-ehrlich-institut und allen
beteiligten bestmöglich unterstützt
werden dass auch in den nächsten tagen
tun jeder tag früher gehen wir einen
zugelassenen impfstoff haben hilft leid
zu mindern und auch todesfälle zu
vermeiden und gleichzeitig ist es eben
ein hohes gut aus meiner sicht eine
ordentliche zulassung zu erreichen das
wird die erste ordentliche zulassung
eines impfstoffes auf der welt dann sein
mein name ist bader vom ard
hauptstadtstudio ich habe eine frage an
sie herr sparen
sie hat mir schon ausgeführt mehrfach
warum sie sich für die zulassung
entschieden haben könnten sie für die
bürger leicht verständlich noch mal
erklären warum welche faktoren da noch
weitergehend geprüft werden die jetzt
eben in großbritannien und in den usa
womöglich nicht geprüft worden damit das
noch mal leicht nachvollziehbar
es wird schlicht und ergreifend bei
diesem verfahren bei einer zulassung
auch tiefer in die daten gegangen also
feinkörniger die daten geprüft
intensiver geprüft es gab und gibt es ja
auch veröffentlichte nachweis für
sicherheit und wirksamkeit aber es wird
einfach tiefer rein gegangen so zu sagen
weil man auch eben diese zusätzliche
zeit hat oder sich nimmt dafür dann eben
auch besser die daten auswerten zu
können zu schauen wo es eventuell für
bestimmte gruppen bestimmte situationen
auch zusätzliche risiken gibt und es ist
parallel auch das ist ja was was stark
macht ein verfahren an dem sich eben die
27 nationalen behörden beteiligen also
sozusagen die große expertise aus dem
paul-ehrlich-institut aus dem
französischen aus dem niederländischen
aus dem spanischen aus dem polnischen
institut das fließt alles zusammen und
sorgen dafür dass es eine noch größere
sicherheit auch in der beurteilung gibt
und ich will dass ich will das einfach
mal so so also aussprechen ich stelle
mir manchmal vor wie es eigentlich
gewesen wenn in einer note zulassung
national wer als allererste auf der welt
gekämpft hätten denn wenn die debatte
gehabt im zweifel die ich manchmal jetzt
schon per e-mail kriege wir sind nicht
ihre versuchskaninchen
also es ist es gibt ja beides ich krieg
von pflegekräften beides die einen sagen
mir herr spahn ich erwarte schon dass
wenn sie beginnen zu impfen dass wir mit
als erstes dran kommen weil wir stehen
an der front sozusagen im risiko und ich
krieg auch von pflegekräften der hinweis
ich lasse mich vielleicht impfen aber
nicht als erstes weil ich will irgendwie
ich bin unsicher nicht versuchskaninchen
sein so ist das wort dann dazu und
deswegen finde ich diesen ansatz wir
machen eine ordentliche zulassung mit
einem ordentlichen intensiven
prüfverfahren fachlich durch die
behörden ganz ganz wichtig dass alle
sich darauf verlassen können dass ist
gut und intensiv geprüft worden nichts
ist wichtiger beim
als vertrauen in den impfstoffen der
gesunden menschen vererbt werden soll
auch eine frage zum impfen nochmal die
uns digital zugegangen ist von dieser
braun presseagentur gesundheit richtet
sich vermutlich an herrn wähler für
welchen zeitpunkt ist mit dem anlass der
impfverordnung zu rechnen und muss die
impfempfehlung der stiko vor diesem
anlass noch präzisiert werden angesichts
der lieferschwierigkeiten bei pfizer und
biontech weil die eben verordnung andere
des ministeriums ist kennt er hat
vielleicht zur zweiten frage haben jetzt
sind also zum ersten wir rechnen heute
das ist wiederum bei der beim robert
koch institut mit der finalen
stellungnahme der ständigen
impfkommission die jetzt eben die
eingegangenen positionierung noch mal
überarbeitet oder ausgearbeitet
ausgewertet hat und dann die
stellungnahme überarbeitet und wir haben
parallel und werden parallel die
impfverordnung den entwurf überarbeiten
heute noch mal was ungewöhnlich ist aber
weil das ein besonderer besonders
wichtiges form ist noch mal in die
abstimmung geben mit den ländern mit den
verbänden mit den anderen ressorts
wir werden auch abwarten die
bundestagsdebatte die es morgen und
übermorgen gibt zum thema impfen und
priorisieren und und den
rahmenbedingungen und erst nachdem der
deutsche bundestag sich mit dem thema
beschäftigt hat werde ich dann
wahrscheinlich am freitag die verordnung
abschließend unterzeichnen sie nach
ergänzen nur ganz kurz die korrektur ist
könnte er heute oder morgen die stücke
nicht sicher ob es heute kommt aber wir
rechnen morgen wahrscheinlich damit wenn
alles glatt läuft heute wird das
digitale monitoring live geschaltet um
17 uhr und die zweite frage nach den
präzisierungen wegen
lieferschwierigkeiten können sie dazu
noch das ergänzen welche präzisierung
wegen die frage war ob die
impfempfehlung der stiko vor dem anlass
noch einmal präzisiert werden muss
angesichts von lieferschwierigkeiten bei
pfizer und bayon tag also spielt das
eine rolle weil das eine ist ja die
priorisierung
die frau bog sie auch aus
gedrückt hat die ja sozusagen auch
mehrere gruppen parallel möglich macht
zu beginn und dann kommen natürlich auch
pragmatisch praktische erwägungen dazu
ich denke viele bundesländer werden
insbesondere auch in den alten
einrichtungen beginnen zu impfen was ja
auch sinn macht angesichts der
risikosituation und gleichzeitig haben
wir eben von anfang an deswegen
priorisieren wir ja nicht ausreichend
impfstoff sondern das wächst dann
langsam hoch und dadurch dass wir eben
im den ersten im ersten quartal mit etwa
11 bis 13 millionen impfdosen rechnen
dürfen werden wir im zug um zug das
weiter hochfahren und dann mehr und mehr
dann auch aus der prioritären gruppe
entsprechend impfen können also das
grundprinzip dahinter bleibt aber gleich
und deswegen führt das jetzt nicht zu
einer veränderung in der priorisierung
sondern die zeitliche abfolge ergibt
sich sozusagen anders vielleicht ist es
ein missverständnis wenn sich neue
erkenntnisse ergeben sollten bei anderen
impfstoffen dann könnte es sein dass man
noch einmal nachjustiert also wenn man
sicher wüsste dass ein impfstoff ganz
bestimmt die übertragung des virus auf
andere menschen unterbindet das könnte
noch mal ein nachjustieren erfordern
dass es aber auch schon angelegt
der entwurf der stiko empfehlung hatte
ja schon eine fußnote dass das ein
lebendes dokument sein soll wo also
immer wieder neue erkenntnisse eingebaut
werden aber an den ethischen
grundprinzipien wird sich nichts ändern
an den ethischen grundwerten wird sich
nichts ändern
und je mehr impfstoff man hat desto mehr
kann man dann wenn sie so wollen in der
priorisierung liste vorangehen aber die
reihenfolge wird sich dadurch natürlich
nicht ändern wir hoffen dass wir
möglichst schnell alle hoffen wir dass
wahrscheinlich dass wir möglichst
schnell da voranschreiten können dann
machen wir im saal weiter bei handy
ordensfrauen die orange hp herr minister
die ema hat eine zulassung zum 23.12
noch nicht offiziell bestätigt versuchen
sie hier durch das öffentliche pushen
dieses datums von außen fakten zu
schaffen
oder haben sie schon eine bestätigung
von der ema dass dieses datum
eingehalten
und der niedersächsische
ministerpräsident war gestern in der ard
gesagt dass er davon ausgeht dass es zu
geringeren liefermengen kommen wird als
erwartet dann haben sie dazu hinweise
da ich die meldung wie sie auf meinem
weg also ich weiß nicht wann sie
wahrgenommen haben ich habe die meldung
zum 23.12 bestätigt wahrgenommen auf
meinem weg hoch in einer titan meldung
und habe sich so gelesen als wir das
bestätigt worden
von der agentur aber es ist eben auch
unsere informationen das ist verteidigt
also der 23 sitze nicht vor heiligabend
dass ich finde ich das plausibel vor
heiligabend erreicht werden soll
das ist jedenfalls mein
informationsstand ich habe eigentlich
nur wiedergegeben was ich von medien
erfahren habe
an dieser stelle und ich unterstelle mal
dass das dann auch korrekt entsprechend
geschickt worden ist bei der ema zur
frage zu herrn ministerpräsidenten weil
und seine einschätzung ist dass das was
ich wahrscheinlich tippe ich weiß ja
weil aufgreift dass ich am sonntag auch
in der ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
gesagt habe was aber auch schon
öffentlich beschrieben war anfang
dezember das eben bei montech weiser
bewegen einen nicht so zügigen
produktionsaufbau wegen einiger probleme
wie eigentlich geplant zu beginnen nicht
ganz so viele mengen wird ausliefern
können
die ursprünglichen und zwar in alle
empfänger wie ursprünglich einmal
geplant war aber das ist wie gesagt eine
information von anfang dezember
die auch schon anfang dezember medial
besprochen worden ist und öffentlich die
ich noch mal wiederholt habe am sonntag
die dann aber nochmal erneut medial
gesprochen worden ist ist aber die
gleiche information jetzt dieselbe
information sagen würde weiß ich nicht
in der situation sind was die gleiche
information wie sagt dazu erfolgt nicht
durch die zuweisung natürlich die
produktion genau
wir machen im saal weiter behände
ersparen wenn es am 23
oder wissen 23 die zulassung da sind
dann könnte dann verbindlich in
deutschland mit dem impfen begonnen
werden doch während der feiertage von
zweite frage von moderner der zweite
kandidat ist er zugelassen werden könnte
noch in diesem jahr oder anfang januar
hat deutschland separat nichts bestellt
bekommt über die eu nur relativ wenig da
ist nur wenig gestellt von 7,5 millionen
also dosen für 7,5 millionen deutsche
ist geplant bei moderner nochmal
nachzukaufen auch um schneller helfen zu
können
also zuerst einmal wenn die zulassung
erfolgen sollte und ich sage noch einmal
es wird ja noch geprüft kann jederzeit
eine information sicher geben in der
prüfung
weil sonst müsste man ja nicht noch
prüfen
bis dahin wenn die zulassung zum 23 12
erfolgen sollte
dann geht es übrigens im nächsten
schritt auch um die chargenfreigabe das
ist übrigens bei grippeimpfstoffen jedem
impfstoff so dass die jeweilige charge
vom paul-ehrlich-institut in diesem fall
dann jeweils auch noch mal frei zu geben
und zu prüfen ist und auch da noch mal
eine sicherheit zu haben dass das was
ausgeliefert wird die chance auch über
einstand mit dem was zugelassen worden
ist in der qualität und beschaffenheit
und dann werden wir uns natürlich mit
dem hersteller darum bemühen dass
schnellstmöglich eine auslieferung
erfolgt an die bundesländer dort dann
durch die bundesländer an die jeweiligen
impfzentren sodass ich maximal mit zwei
bis vier tagen späterem im staat rechnen
die zweite frage zu moderner ich weiß
jetzt nicht wo sie die 7,5 millionen
haben von den 160 millionen dosen die
die europäische union bei moderner
gestellt hat 80 millionen plus 80
millionen optional die option ist
gezogen worden jetzt bin ich tatsächlich
gerade in meinem kopf am kam nach der
genauen zahl aber wir haben
über 30 millionen dosen wenn ich es
richtig im kopf ich kann hier nicht die
genaue zahl gerade sagt aber deutlich
mehr als die zahl die sie gerade genannt
haben auch von moderner impfstoff für
deutschland gesichert
auch überproportional weil von den 280
millionen wollten nicht mehr alle
mitgliedsstaaten ihren anteil haben
deswegen hat deutschland
überproportional von dem optionalen 80
millionen dosen daneben auch im stoff
gesichert es ist aber tatsächlich so
dass zu beginn weil moderner ja das
gleiche thema hat und dort auch die
vereinigten staaten sehr früh sehr viel
sich für die erstauslieferung gesichert
haben werden wir zu beginn erstmal
sozusagen mit einer halben millionen
dosen starten in den ersten wochen von
moderner nach zulassungen die natürlich
auch erst mal deinen erfolgen muss im
januar und das wird eine aufwachsen
richtung sommer aber wir haben uns dort
nicht mehr sichern können als sie gerade
erwähnt aber sie kaufen jetzt nicht noch
mal nach ob wir wir haben vereinbart in
der europäischen union das nationale
bilaterale verträge jeweils erst
erfolgen nachdem die europäischen
verträge final geschlossen sind danach
wie er es final auch mit anderen
abschließend und verbindlich verträge
mit anderen zeichnen
ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass wir
auch mit einigen der hersteller die
jetzt sehr frühzeitig in der zulassung
sind zusätzliche nationale verträge
schließen darüber reden wir natürlich
insbesondere auch mit den deutschen
herstellern aber eben auch
beispielsweise mit modernen eine frage
die dazu vielleicht passt angela
mißlbeck vom ärzte nachrichtendienst
fragt digital benötigt man für die
bislang zu erwartende menge an impfstoff
dosen tatsächlich die aufwendige
logistik mit rund um die uhr besetzten
impfzentren
also es ist grundsätzlich so dass ich es
besser finde dass wir in zentren
einsatzbereit haben ab heute
und weil wir vor einigen monaten auch
noch damit rechnen müssten dass
möglicherweise sogar noch früher eine
zulassung erfolgen könnte und der
impfstoff dann etwas später kommt als
umgekehrt der impfstoff wäre schon da
und wir hätten die logistik und die
infrastruktur nicht das wäre noch viel
schwerer glaube ich irgendwie zu
vermitteln und ja es wird natürlich so
seien dadurch dass es im ersten quartal
um die 11 bis 13 millionen
impfstoffdosen stand heute sein wird
dass die impfzentren nicht alle im
volllast die ganze zeit sein werden um
es mal so zu formulieren sondern dass
sich das langsam entwickelt und langsam
hoch fährt aber auch das gibt dir
zumindest die chance die prozesse dann
auch tag um tag und mit dem immer weiter
steigenden zahlen an impfungen und
empfingen dann weiter zu optimieren
also wenn es jetzt schon so ist hätte
auch lieber noch mehr dosen natürlich
ein start wie jeder andere staat der
welt auch aber wenn es jetzt schon so
ist gibt es uns zumindest die
möglichkeit die prozesse immer weiter zu
optimieren
wir machen den saal weiter bei frau
geheim rebecca mir hätte deutsches
ärzteblatt ich hätte doch mal eine frage
zu dem thema eben stiko auch ohne
impfempfehlung und dieser diskussion
mainz gesetzt was aber vor allem am
wochenende noch mal gelaufen ist wie
stehen sie dazu ihr schwarm bz was
entgegnen sie den fdp bundestags
kollegen dazu und die zweite frage geht
in richtung gesundheitsämter herr wieder
sie hatten ja auch gesagt dass die
gesundheitsämter überlastet sind die
digitalisierung der gesundheitsämter
soll ja zum ersten ersten verbessert
werden wie wer auf welchem punkt stehen
wir da jetzt mitte dezember also zuerst
einmal wir haben eine gesetzliche
grundlage das dritte bevölkerungsschutz
gesetz hat im übrigen ja auch schon eine
ford priorisierung vorgenommen auf
grundlage auch der empfehlung des
deutschen ethikrates der leopoldina und
der ständigen impfkommission da steht
nämlich eben dass insbesondere die
älteren die besonders verwundbaren durch
dieses virus diejenigen die im
gesundheitswesen beschäftigt sind und
die die für die öffentliche ordnung auch
wichtig sind die personen gruppen
bevorzugt geben werden sollen und
übergibt dann so zu
die weitere detaillierung die ja auch
beständig anzupassen sein wird wo wir
gerade schon gesagt worden ist bei
verschiedenen impfstoffen verschiedenen
erkenntnissen möglicherweise daneben in
einer rechtsverordnung des
bundesministeriums für gesundheit sind
übrigens auch bei anderen impfstoffen
kein ungewöhnlicher vorgang ständige
impfkommission empfiehlt und dann
meistens der gemeinsame bundesausschuss
die selbstverwaltung des
gesundheitswesens entscheidet in der
folge es ist zudem ein impfstoff der
ausschließlich sich im bundesbesitz jahr
befinden serviert das ist noch mal was
anderes als der freie zugang sozusagen
in anderen bereichen zu beginn ist es
eben ausschließlich ein staatlich dann
erworbener impfstoff wo dann eben auf
grundlage des gesetzes und der
verordnung mit den ländern zusammen dann
das impfen vorgenommen wird und wir sind
uns in der bundesregierung einig dass
das eben auch die rechtsgrundlage ist
auf der wir agieren können und wollen
den gesetzentwurf den sie angesprochen
haben den kenn ich bis jetzt nicht der
nicht mehr auch noch nicht vor
ich habe gehört dass sie am donnerstag
beraten werden soll aber da ich einen
gesetzentwurf der donnerstag beraten
werden sollte am dienstag noch nicht
kenne kann ich ihnen jetzt noch nicht
beurteilen
ja zu der digitalen aus statt in der
gesundheits- und wärme rund 412
gesundheitsämter in deutschland und wir
reden hier über drei software die immer
wieder in den medien stehen und die sind
auch zentral sein ist das deutsche
elektronische meldung informationssystem
das wird noch mal einen kenntnisstand im
januar auch überall angeschlossen sein
dann haben wir die melde software die ja
nicht nur mit 19 sondern alle diese
ganzen meldungen salmonellosen hiv
welche krankheit noch immer auf nimmt
dieses öffnet ist inzwischen meines
wissens bei rund drei viertel aller
deutschen gesundheitsämter genutzt und
dann gibt es noch eine weitere software
die hauptsächlich für die kontakt
verfolgung wichtiges sommers und sommers
soll ja weiter ausgerollt werden
ich habe mich die zahlen genau im kopf
wie das aussieht im september
entschuldigen eben im januar aber auch
das wird natürlich dann auf alle bundes
gesundheitsämter ausgerollt das ist ja
auch ein bundesbeschluss ein beschluss
dieses corona kabinetts meines wissens
der ministerpräsident der
ministerpräsidenten exakt das ist das
eine das andere ist aber natürlich auch
diese software muss natürlich auch dann
von den mitarbeitern mitarbeitern
gelernt werden das sind ja immer zwei
paar schuhe und auch das war zügig
vorbereitet und geht seiner wege und die
digitalisierung klappt aber natürlich
nur insofern als eben auch die
mitarbeiter entsprechend geschult werden
ich kann kurz ergänzen ich hab gerade
die zahl bekommen er ist jetzt leider
nicht mehr da aber musste wahrscheinlich
ein 48,6 millionen dosen moderner haben
wir uns gesichert von der europäischen
von der europäischen 180 millionen es
ist deswegen wie gesagt überproportional
bei einige bundesländer
einige mitgliedstaaten auf ihren anteil
verzichtet haben und werden dann ich
nehme mir noch mal eine frage dazu das
geht noch mal um das thema impfen diese
frage ist vielleicht die kommen ja nicht
live in dem moment wo ich hier vorlesen
sondern liegt hier schon etwas länger
von der kollegin henrike roßbach
süddeutsche zeitung es geht noch mal um
das thema notfall zulassung
vielleicht ist die überholt durch das
neue datum was vorhin hier besprochen
wurde sie fragt aber nochmal
grundsätzlich wie wird abgewogen
zwischen den zusätzlichen toten durch
einen späteren impfbeginn und den wert
einer ordentlichen zulassung für das
vertrauen und wann könnte die
entscheidung für letzteres also notfall
zu lassen kippen
und dann stellt sie noch die frage warum
ist es so wichtig die kleine gruppe
potenzieller ins gegner nicht mit einer
zulassung zu irritieren
mein eindruck ist es gibt die impfgegner
und dann gibt es aber eben auch viele
die erstmal eine zurückhaltung haben
beim neuen impfstoff in zwei
verschiedene dinge
und die erst mal im zweifel sagen ich
warte erstmal ab oder ich schaue mir das
erst mal an ich werde mich impfen lasse
zeigen die umfragen viele sagen ich
werde mich eigentlich wahrscheinlich
schon impfen lassen aber ich weiß noch
nicht so ganz genau ich gucke erstmal
und gerade für diese gruppe die nicht
sofort sagt wie ich persönlich ja klar
dass ich mich impfen wenn ich dran bin
sondern die er sagt ich guck erstmal ist
doch die frage
wie zugelassen wird und wir die prozesse
zur zulassung sind eine ganz ganz
wichtige und genau dafür machen wir eben
diesen diesen weg und das ist ja richtig
beschrieben das ist ein abwägungsprozess
den man sicherlich wenn es jetzt ein
sehr großes zeitliches auseinanderfallen
gegeben hätte da keine frau büchse im
zweifel auch dann noch mal was zu sagen
dann noch mal anders hätte bewerten
müssen arbeiten mehr wert den diese
ordentliche zulassung ich sage noch
einmal die erste ordentliche zulassung
dann weltweit bringt auch für vertrauen
und verlässlichkeit zur impfung aber ich
sage auch noch mal dazu auch innerhalb
europas
bitte sehr diesen aspekt nicht völlig
weg zu lassen dass es auch viel für
verlässlichkeit und vertrauen innerhalb
der europäischen union tut diesen weg in
dieser schweren zeit gemeinsam zu gehen
ist jetzt ein unterschied von zwei
wochen zwischen einer note zulassung und
einer ordentlichen zulassung aus meiner
sicht einer der unbedingt eben auch
verantwortet werden kann
ich kann ihm nur 100% zustimmt
vielleicht noch eine information
wir machen ja zusammen mit der
universität der vorzeit märz diesen
jahres regelmäßig umfragen kosten wo
diese studie die wirklich sehr sehr
wichtiges und die beteiligten dort 70
prozent der menschen die sich über
impfstoff informieren möchten auch was
über nebenwirkungen wissen ja das ist
eine menge
und natürlich ist gerade deshalb auch
die die prüfung dieser unterlagen so
wichtig und das heißt also ich halte das
auch für absolut wichtig wir wir müssen
hier so transparent und offen wie
möglich umgehen wie wir das auch später
tun werden wenn wir dieses digitale impf
monitoren aufgebaut haben dann werden
auch die daten dann auch die die
unerwünschten nebenwirkungen wie fieber
schmerzen an der einstichstelle das wird
transparent aufgezeigt werden das ist
sehr sehr wichtig damit das vertrauen
der bevölkerung auch da ist vielleicht
nur noch als ergänzung es gibt diesen
satz beginnings massa der anfang zählt
und das ist gerade bei einer
wie wir sie so glaube ich in den letzten
jahrzehnten nicht mehr erlebt haben
impfkampagne gegen die korona pandemie
extrem entscheidend dass wir da jetzt
nicht in irgendeinen crash reingehen
dass das alles gut sorgfältig und
transparent vorbereitet ist
das heißt einmal organisatorisch
vorbereitet aber eben auch inhaltlich
und mit blick auf vertrauensbildung und
sicherheit und ich glaube ich muss auch
was diese abwägung anbelangt einfach
darauf hin deuten diese zu einfachen
abwägungen wir haben jetzt noch zwei
wochen längere zulassung und so und so
viele tote passieren in der zeit die
sind sehr krude war natürlich amt oder
auch passieren weil mehr infektionen
stattfinden also die vermeidung von
todesfällen findet nicht unilateral nur
durch die impfung statt wodurch eine
frühere impfung sondern eben auch durch
unser verhalten in dieser pandemie
deswegen waren nicht so ein bisschen
davor das so ganz hart gegeneinander zu
stellen ich glaube das ist zu
vereinfacht ich verstehe warum man das
so denkt und wir sind alle sehr
ungeduldig mich eingeschlossen ich sehe
wirklich die tage aber ich glaube das
ist besser wenn wir das jetzt gut und
ordentlich und sorgfältig alle bekommen
und dann auch darauf vertrauen können
vielleicht gibt es im saal noch nachher
fragen zum thema impfungen und wein gibt
es aber auch viele zum thema pflege oder
allgemein zu corona und weihnachten
deswegen nehme ich jetzt mal eine von
holger möhle bonner general-anzeiger der
möchte gerne von einem podiumsgästen
wissen wie und mit wie vielen personen
verbringen sie weihnachten wer möchte
gehen dann fange ich mal an ich werde
mit meiner kleinen haushalts familie
weihnachten verbringen drei personen
weil
mein mann und ich beide im
gesundheitssystem arbeiten und natürlich
bereit stehen und hintergrund dienste
haben und wir haben uns entschieden
nicht die großeltern zu besuchen dieses
jahr eine vierköpfige familie meine
töchter gehen in vor quarantäne
meine frau ebenso und ich bin mehr oder
weniger sowieso immer in quarantäne zu
meinem büro und wir werden unsere
schwiegereltern als zweite einheit haben
die ebenfalls extrem vorsichtig sind und
von daher das ist der kontakt den wir
weihnachten haben an weihnachten
heiligabend weihnachten bin ich mit
meinem mann alleine erstmalig in dieser
besonderen besonderen situation wenn es
geht mit anmeldung und athene
bedingungen werden sie die christmette
besuchen aber das liegt jetzt eben auch
an den bedingungen zu denen das möglich
ist oder nicht
ich habe zwei grundschulkinder wir sind
zu viert
wir gehen ab freitagmittag alle in die
vor quarantäne wir haben verzichtet
dieses jahr die großeltern einzuladen
oder zu besuchen und werden mit der
zweiten einheit mit meiner schwester und
ihrem neugeborenen kind und dem älteren
kind gemeinsam feiern dann machen wir
weiter bei henderson
ich habe zwei fragen eine an herrn
sparen sie sagten eine dritte welle
zeichnet sich ab ehe die zweite
abgeflacht war taucht der begriff der
welle eigentlich noch zur beschreibung
der dynamik den welle heißt eigentlich
wir haben einen wellenberg dann ein
wellental dann
bellenberg wenn das direkt ineinander
übergeht und was würde das bedeuten wenn
wir zehn tage nach heiligabend dann auf
einmal durch die dann doch merken
kontakte einen weiteren anstieg haben
ihre das vierte bälle oder wir und die
frage anhand wieder dass sie sagten
22.000 tote an oder mit corona wir
wissen dass gerade bei den kritikern der
relevanz dieser zahlen war gesagt wird
ja dieses an oder mit an wird häufig
genommen es ist aber in wahrheit gar
nicht die todesursache kann man das
genaue ausdifferenzieren oder welche
bedeutung hat diese unterscheidung zu
meinen ich glaube zu beiden fragen wenn
ich das sagen darf dann vielleicht auch
noch etwas
ergänzend zur welle findet jedenfalls
ganz spannend zur frage welche das finde
ich übrigens ist ein berechtigter
hinweis weil welle so gerät irgendwie
wieso am strand ist was weg und dieses
virus ist ja nie ganz weg
in der gesellschaft ist auch im sommer
ja offenkundig nicht weg gewesen oder in
der phase geringe infektionen hatten
es ist sozusagen in unterschiedlicher
dynamik unterwegs und entweder gut unter
kontrolle oder eben wie wir es jetzt
leider erleben im nicht unter kontrolle
und deswegen kann man über den begriff
der welle tatsächlich streiten was wir
aber gesehen haben ist ja und das fand
ich jedenfalls schon bemerkenswert ist
eben das sozusagen in dem runtergehen
der infektionszahlen wir jetzt in den
letzten fünf sechs sieben acht tagen
gesehen haben das waren ganz vielen
bundesländern wieder in die andere
richtung gehen das ist jedenfalls ein
phänomen das ich jetzt mit dieser
dritten welle beschrieben aber eben ein
assist was sehr deutlich gemacht wie
wichtig ist jetzt wahr
so schwer es ist diese zusätzlichen
maßnahmen zu ergreifen um das unter
kontrolle zu kriegen ja selbst der
ersten frage ich muss zunächst noch mal
sagen dass die der lok tonleiter gewirkt
hat er hat er dieses exponentielle
wachstum aufgehoben und man war in einem
plateau das heißt also diese kontakt
beschränkung prinzipiell funktioniert
das und wir sehen halt jetzt wieder ein
ansteigen weshalb ist eben nicht
genügend funktion wir können das auch
berechnen
wir haben berechnet dass wir etwa nur 40
prozent der kontakte reduzieren konnten
das sind modellierungen und wir brauchen
mindestens 60 prozent da sind sich viele
wissenschaftler einig zu der frage mit
den todesfällen die zahlen die ich nenne
sind die zahlen die uns von den
gesundheitsämtern übermittelt werden und
selbstverständlich könnte man es nur
genau sagen wenn jeder dieser
verstorbenen seziert wird eine obduktion
unterworfen wird was natürlich nicht
geschieht
es gibt aber eine publikation aus
deutschland und auch gerade eine
publikation die von pathologen durch
federführend gemacht wurde die auch
selber das vorher kritisierten diese
angabe und in dieser publikation ich
glaube sie war im deutschen ärzteblatt
wurde festgestellt dass von den toten
die dann alles untersucht von 86%
wirklich an dem virus an der infektion
verstorben war
ich möchte aber dazu noch folgendes
sagen es gibt natürlich auch bei den
todesfällen eine dunkelziffer
es wird natürlich auch menschen geben in
unserem land die versterben ohne dass
man diagnostiziert hat dass sie corona
hatten weil es ja schlaganfälle unter
anderem verursacht weil das gefäßsystem
ihr angegriffen wird insofern halte ich
die zahl die ich dort nenne das ist die
offizielle zahl eher für eine
unterschätzung der waren todesfällen tco
widmen vielleicht kann ich noch
ergänzend zu an und mit corona das ist
ja auch immer wenn sie schon gesagt
haben einen kritikpunkt und ich habe das
auch diskutiert in einem telefonat und
der kollege meinte dass er das sehr gut
klinisch unterscheiden kann also
erkenntnis kann sich sehr gut und ich
denke das ist das eine und dann gibt es
ganz viele aspekte die zum teil wieder
ja auch schon gesagt hat es gibt auch
spätfolgen wie wir sehen nach 1
therapie zum beispiel wenn sie
intensivmedizinisch versorgt worden dass
dann eine besondern sagen so eine
sekundäre entzündung der leber der
gallenwege passieren kann an denen man
dann auch versterben kann die sind
natürlich wochen des monate nach der
eigentlichen infektionen sind aber
trotzdem an den folgen der infektion
gestorben
und ich sehe das genauso wie agila immer
die kritik dass so viele getestet werden
was anderes sterben ist es genauso auch
andersrum das wahrscheinlich viele
sterben und gar nicht getestet wurden
gar nicht obduziert worden
und ja es gibt einfach sehr viele
aspekte oder andere erkrankungen
thrombosen embolien die ausgelöst werden
durch die infektion
die aber darauf zurückzuführen sind und
natürlich ist dann die todesursache ein
organversagen oder die embolie aber die
ursache ist trotzdem dass wir immer eine
frage dazu von der kollegin tanja mastro
boni von la repubblica sie fragt nochmal
oder bittet darum nochmal genauer zu
erklären wie es kommt dass die korona
todesfälle in deutschland steigen und so
anders sind als während dieser ersten
sogenannten welle als deutschland im
vergleich mit anderen ländern so
niedrige todesraten vorwies das gibt es
leider eine ganz einfache erklärung
die haben wir auch schon wirklich sehr
sehr häufig gegeben wir haben ja eine
tabelle in unserem situationsbericht wo
die inzidenz also die fallzahlen pro
altersgruppe man sieht und diese tabelle
haben wir jetzt auf fünf jahren
deren alter auf gegliedert und man sieht
eben leider dass in den alten und
hochaltrigen altersgruppen die inzidenz
am höchsten sind also wir haben jetzt
das kann ich kaum lesen 631 pro 100000
bei den 90 plus bei den hochaltrigen
menschen und es ist so und da gibt es
auch eine neue publikation jetzt mal die
casetech berechnen also nicht nur die
todesfall zahlen die wir anhand der
meldezahlen bereichen noch mal einen
anhand von systematischen reviews
überprüft doch wird angegeben dass die
wenn über 80 über 85 jährige infiziert
werden davon sterben 15 prozent case
vorteile direkt 15 prozent und bei denen
in meiner altersgruppe bis 60 65
das sterben auch schon ist die kest lg
ratio auch schon bei mehr als 1 prozent
ich glaube 1,4 prozent also je älter die
patienten werden desto größer ist leider
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass sie schwer
krank werden und versterben es hängt mit
der altersstruktur zusammen und darum
nochmal diese bitte wenn wir insgesamt
in deutschland die zahlen runter
bekommen
denn wäre natürlich auch die infektion
nicht so schnell weitergegeben das ist
der ganz entscheidende punkt und wir
können eben nicht alle menschen schätzen
wir müssen das schützen wir müssen das
natürlich tun aber es klingt eben leider
nicht und je mehr menschen in
deutschland infiziert sind egal welche
altersgruppe desto größer ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es eben auf
einen anderen menschen in jeglicher
anderen altersgruppe übertragen wird
das ist die altersgruppe ist der
entscheidende punkt wir haben nun mal
eine demografie in deutschland
ich glaube wir haben 27 millionen
menschen über 65 ich habe es nicht genau
über 23 millionen über 60 22 64
also auf jeden fall haben wir sind eine
relativ alte gesellschaft weltweit
verglichen und darum ist dieses virus
für unser land eben auch von besonderer
bedeutung das muss man einfach immer vor
augen haben ich habe jetzt noch vier
fragen hier im saal 3d digital sind die
würde ich gerne alle noch annehmen weil
es auch nochmal andere aspekte sind dann
aber die freiheit die frageliste
schließen weil wir uns doch der stunde
nähern die wir hier als
die mitte gesetzt haben in kohat zeichen
für veranstaltungen wir machen im saal
weiter bei herrn jung mit der bitte
vielleicht um kurze fragen und möglichst
kurze antworten
ich versuche auch noch zur alten
gesellschaft also die ausbrüche in den
alten und pflegeheim explodieren
ich würde von project und dann will er
noch mal interessieren was sie konkret
fordern beziehungsweise was jetzt am
besten wäre dagegen zu tun und frau box
sie haben ja ihre im impfplan der stiko
die bundestagsabgeordneten nicht
priorisiert jetzt will herr schäuble und
auch das innenministerium das die
bundestagsabgeordneten schneller geld
werden also priorität priorisiert werden
was halten sie davon ja ich kann ja mal
anfangen
ich denke da sind wir auf einem guten
weg in den altenheimen die hygieneregeln
müssen immer beachtet werden wir müssen
die konzepte unterstützen mit mit
testungen mit antigenen pcr basierten
testung und die leute müssen immer
wieder neu aufgeklärt werden dass eine
testung nicht die hygieneregeln ersetzen
kann ich denke dass es ein großer eine
große gefahr dass man sich da ein
falscher sicherheit wiegt und natürlich
auch die impfung
die ja bald kommen wird ist natürlich
auch ein schutz dann die altenheime und
das sind glaube ich die größten drei
säulen die wir haben also mehr testen
sowohl das personal als auch die
besucher als auch die bewohner strikte
einhaltung der hygieneregeln verwendung
von fb zwei masken so weit das geht das
ist bei den bewohnern natürlich manchmal
schwierig aufgrund der erkrankung und
die impfungen möglichst schnell dort
einzuführen
es gibt empfehlungen vom
robert-koch-institut wir haben gerade
letzte woche zusammen mit dem pflege
beauftragt auch noch mal ein papier
erstellt da gibt es wirklich sehr sehr
klare rezepte wie man damit umgehen soll
ich möchte aber noch mal was sagen wir
haben unglaublich rund 800 oder 850.000
menschen in der buchhaltung gruppe die
so leben die ganzen anderen leben aber
anders und die müssen natürlich auch
geschützt werden und das heißt sie
können wir eben nur schützen und
insgesamt die ganzen zahlen nach unten
bringen und dann muss man natürlich in
täglichen umgang wir sehen dass zum
beispiel bei den alters instanzen
diejenigen von den alten menschen die
noch selber unterwegs sind mobil sind
die sich selber schützen können die tun
das auch in einem hohen maße also das
ist auch deren verhalten natürlich
wichtig aber wir haben eben diese
grundregeln abstand halten hygiene maske
tragen vor allen dingen wir haben
modellierungen da gibt es ein
international health metrics evaluation
institut wenn wir alle die masken tragen
zu jeder zeit in geschlossenen räumen
reduzieren wir die anzahl der todesfälle
und der übertragung wir haben tools wir
müssen sie halt wirklich anwenden wenn
ich nur eins ergänzen auf diese hygiene
konzepte des lka gibt es seit april die
übernahme der kosten für
schutzausrüstungen pflegeheim gibt es
seit april die pflegeversicherung zeit
seit april mittlerweile einige hundert
millionen euro zusätzlich für die
schutzausrüstung in den
pflegeeinrichtungen
wir haben zusätzlich seit dem 15 die
tests in den pcr tests die vorher schon
übernommen wurden wenn der gds anordnete
die schnelltests wir haben zusätzlich
jetzt die 90.000 paketen aber zusätzlich
ich manchmal den eindruck habe es werde
der eindruck dass diese 90.000 pakete
das erste mal sind der schutzausrüstung
für pflegeeinrichtungen zur verfügung
steht seit april können sie eingekauft
werden und werden
refinanziert und das passiert auch und
bemühen uns übrigens auch gerade darum
dass dann gegebenenfalls auch über eine
zulassung bei monoklonalen antikörpern
da wo es evidenz gibt wer das genau die
gruppe von patienten wo man dann bei
einer infektion sehr frühzeitig daneben
nach ärztlicher entscheidung um auch
dort ein schwersten verlauf zu vermeiden
dann hin tätig werden würde auch dafür
bemühen wir uns zusätzliche mir schon
wichtig seit april gibt es konzepte und
auch übernahme der kosten für
schutzausrüstung sofort die zweite frage
beantwortet wird zu den abgeordneten
würde ich nochmal zwei fragen die online
angekommen sind zum thema pflege einfach
zusammenstellen dass wir bei dem komplex
vielleicht bleiben können
die kollegin polona vier jahres von rtv
slowenien frankreich deutschland dabei
dass die besucher in pflegeheimen noch
immer möglich sind und rasmus
buchsteiner von media pioneer fragt
welche versäumnisse der politik und der
verantwortlichen sehen sie vor ort also
in pflegeheimen und warum hat es bis zur
letzten mpk gedauert mit einer
verpflichtung des personal in den heimen
regelmäßig zu testen
zuerst einmal grundsätzlich dass sie
eine wahnsinnig schwer war schwere
balance zwischen der aussage und auch
dem willen isolierung und jetzt eine
pflegekraft gesagt im gespräch mit der
bundeskanzlerin das war wie gefängnis
ohne gitter die situation im frühjahr wo
ganz ohne besucher und ohne die
möglichkeit dass die einrichtung ist
auch verlassen zu können auch da gab es
ja einschränkungen früher das wieder zu
vermeiden und gleichzeitig bestmöglichen
schutz zu bringen und eine lanze brechen
jetzt vor weihnachten für die
pflegekräfte die stehen nämlich
emotional von allen seiten unter druck
die angehörigen die natürlich sagen ich
möchte aber mein mann meine frau meinen
vater besuchen und natürlich die
schwierige situation in der
pflegeeinrichtung die sowieso schon
häufig nicht einfach aber das noch
zusätzlich
und deswegen braucht es unbedingt und
die werden auch umgesetzt besucht
konzept es wird auch an weihnachten
nicht jeder einfach kommen können wenn
er oder sie will dann muss man einfach
um verständnis bitten
es geht nur nach anmeldung es geht nur
in bestimmten zeiten es geht nur
idealerweise nach einem vorherigen test
und und das ist eben sozusagen die suche
nach der balance zwischen bestmöglichen
schutz und gleichzeitig eben nicht
absoluter isolation wenn ein ausbruch
ist in einer einrichtung werden
natürlich durch die behörden vor ort
gegebenenfalls auch weitergehende
besuchs beschränkungen einschränkungen
umgesetzt und das bringt mich auch zu
der zweiten frage im kern
es ist ja es ist ja schon so ich meine
wenn ein teil des gesundheitssystems
wirklich seit beginn unter dauerstress
ist und das ist anders als für die
meisten anderen bereiche diskussion denn
will man dazu sagen
im sommer gab es für die meisten eine
phase auch wo es mal ruhiger war die
altenpflegeeinrichtung sind seit
frühjahr unter dauerspannung und die
dort beschäftigten auch und die geben
alle ihr bestes in einer echt nicht
einfachen lage was die konzepte angeht
was die hygiene angeht es geht immer
noch besser und deswegen unterstützen
wir bestmöglich und wollen vor allem
auch finanzielle sicherheit geben das
ist das was der bund vor allem auch mit
leisten können das nicht auch noch das
klar ist dann kann man ja darauf
verlassen die kosten werden übernommen
die konzepte die entwickelt werden und
anderes mehr aber es muss natürlich dann
auch gelebt und umgesetzt werden vor ort
die testpflicht ist als pflicht etwas
anderes als ein angebot ist ja schon
eine weitreichende entscheidung was ist
eigentlich mit den beschäftigten die
sich nicht testen lassen wollen das hat
auch gleich arbeitsrechtliche
konsequenzen und geht in viele bereiche
weiter und deswegen ist eine ein
testangebot das gab es vorher schon
möglich zweimal die woche oder eine
testpflicht schon ein ziemlicher
qualitativer unterschied
und zu dieser haben sich eben die länder
jetzt am sonntag auch ohne das also
schon auch mit debatte darüber was das
für eine maßnahme ist aber eben dann
entschlossen in dieser besondere
lage denn die frage nach den
abgeordneten wenn man auch ganz kurz
vielen dank dass eine kleine gruppe aber
ich verstehe dass die viel
aufmerksamkeit erfährt wir haben
formuliert das schon vorrangig
priorisiert werden können menschen die
in basalen bereichen der daseinsvorsorge
und für die aufrechterhaltung zentraler
staatlicher funktion eine schlüsselrolle
besitzen
das heißt da würde das parlament in
auslegung des objektes der stiko das
dann im letzten fall auszulegen
tatsächlich eine solche rolle zukommen
denn das parlament muss laufen das ist
eine zentrale institution in unserer
republik
man kann natürlich darüber nachdenken
das kann ich nicht einschätzen ob es
möglichkeiten gibt dass man das noch
dass man da die zahl noch reduziert dass
man so eine art not eine note
ausstattung zahlenmäßig was die
abgeordneten anbelangen mit blick auf
das parlament haben kann aber das sind
dinge da bin ich völlig überfragt
insgesamt ist das parlament eine
zentrale institution in unserer
gesellschaft und die menschen die das
tatsächlich aufrechterhalten auch nicht
als solcher einfach ersetzbar das sind
ja gewählte abgeordnete da kann man ja
einfach jemand anderen hinstellen
das haben wir auch formuliert also es
geht auch um die ersetzbarkeit es ist
noch mal was anderes wenn sie da jemand
anderen gleich qualifizierten hinstellen
können
der beispielsweise in einem kraftwerk
bestimmte schaltstellen oder so
versorgen kann aber das ist natürlich
bei demokratisch gewählten
volksvertretern ein bisschen andere
situation deswegen verstehe ich dass man
diese gruppe jetzt besonders in den
blick nimmt und da diskutiert dass die
auch sozusagen wie die
regierungsmitglieder behandelt werden
welche als bundesminister für gesundheit
und abgeordnete 1 ergänzen darf ich die
gleichrangigkeit zu der gerade
beschriebenen gruppe sehe ich aber ich
wäre sehr dafür auch in allen anderen
bevölkerung oder berufsgruppen dass wir
zuerst einmal jetzt die auch in den
blick nehmen die sich nicht aktiv selbst
schützen können und das sind zum
beispiel menschen mit demenz kann man
nicht sagen bitte eine schutzmaske
tragen oder anderes mehr
diese gruppe absoluter priorität zuerst
und dann wenn wir zug um zug die anderen
gruppen und auch dem bundestag wie die
bundesregierung
zu gegebener zeit rein kommen lassen bei
mir schon sehr wichtig ein prinzip
zuerst einmal die besonders gefährdet
sind und anders als auch etwa
abgeordnete sich nicht selbst zu
schützen wissen etwa weil sie eben
entsprechend erkrankt jetzt will ich bin
ich falsch verstanden worden sein das
war schon in der nachrangigkeit weil
jetzt auch jährige an sie gerichtet als
an die eigenen kollegen mehr kohle im
saal machen wir weiter
georg ist man vom tagesspiegel herr
minister sparen ich hätte auch noch eine
nachfrage zu den ausbrüchen in den
pflegeheimen dass wir besonders stark in
berlin und was man dort hört wenn es zum
teil 100 infizierte gibt in einem
pflegeheim hat es dort keine
regelmäßigen testungen gegeben das
scheint in der umsetzung einfach
schwierig zu sein könnte der bund bei
der beschaffung vielleicht auch von
schnellen test noch stärker helfen neben
der kostenübernahme und müsste es nicht
auch eine verpflichtende testung dieser
schnelltest von besuchern geben jetzt
gerade mit blick auch auf die
weihnachtszeit in dem bund länder papier
mehr als ja da steht soll der nachweis
eines aktuellen negativen corona tab
verpflichten werden
aber das könnte ja sein dass also das
haben einige bundesländer aus bayern
weiß ich auch umgesetzt das eben bei
hoher intelligenz und in bayern gilt
dass er im moment im grunde für das
ganze bundesland entsprechend auch eine
negativ test entweder gezeigt oder
gemacht werden muss auch für besucherin
besucher vor betreten der
pflegeeinrichtung das macht ohne zweifel
je nach incidents lage und wie gesagt
sie ist im ganzen land oder in weiten
teilen des landes moment sehr hoch
auch viel sinn aber es können eben am
ende nur die länder oder die behörden
vor ort auch anordnen was die frage der
test verfügbarkeit angeht ist die
mittlerweile sehr umfänglich gegeben und
für die kleineren einrichtungen sind
auch nicht selten die verbände die dann
einkaufen und anderes mehr die
verfügbarkeit der tests das ist auch die
rückmeldung die wir haben wird immer
weniger ein problem das problem ist das
personal und der aufwand und ich will ja
nun mal dazu sagen der die pflege ist
der einzige bereich in dem es für das
testen des eigenen personals zusätzliche
vergütung gibt den arztpraxen in den
krankenhäusern in allen anderen
bereichen ist das sozusagen
inklusive wenn man das eigene personal
kess testet wird es nicht extra vergütet
bei der pflege wird es weil man
gegebenenfalls auch zusätzliche personal
braucht extra vergütet also diese
finanzielle teil ist auch da nochmal
adressiert aber natürlich braucht es im
zweifel dieses zusätzliche personal
einige regionen machen dass er
zusätzlich mit unterstützung aus den
hilfs und rettungsdiensten
theoretisch könnten es studierende der
medizin studieren oder andere
studierende auch unter medizinischer
anleitung und aufsicht oder über
pflegerischer machen
da gibt es unterschiedlich kreativ schon
schon konzepte aber ich will schon sagen
dass inter dieser finanzierung style
auch für das zusätzliche personal bei
der pflege gerade ganz besonders und
extras nicht geregelt ist eine frage zum
thema tesco ohne anti gen tests von
panajotis capriles dazu vom
deutschlandfunk erfragt die tests kosten
zwischen 35 und 50 euro warum sind keine
kostenlosen tests über weihnachten
möglich für alle die ihre familien
besuchen wollen und durch einen test das
infektionsrisiko minimieren können
befürchten sich hier keine
zweiklassengesellschaft diejenigen die
sich das leisten kann die ideen nicht in
der übernahme der test posten auch zu
lasten ins war auch der beitragszahler
und steuerzahler regelung vor allem mit
blick auf das gesundheitswesen getroffen
im übrigen ist mittlerweile ist etwa ab
heute fällt mir gerade glaube ich ein
oder ab ja ich glaube ab heute
jedenfalls im laufe des dezembers dass
die übernahme von risikogebiet
reiserückkehrern auch nicht mehr gegeben
test kosten werden nicht mehr übernommen
und gleichzeitig haben wir eine enorme
preisreduzierung immer an dieser tests
haben sich selbst zu sagen selbst calls
kostenbasis testen zu lassen vor wenigen
wochen noch 160 180 130 euro gekostet
wir sind mittlerweile bei 30 bis 40 euro
an vielen stellen im selbstkosten
raich ich sehe den punkt aber ich sehe
jetzt auch nicht dass wir für 80
millionen oder 60 oder 50 millionen
deutsche die test kosten werden
übernehmen können das halte ich jetzt
allerdings anders rum auch nicht für
darstellt bauen schon gar nicht aus den
kosten der krankenversicherung im saal
geht es weiter bei herrn grimm
das ist das richtige ja christian grimm
von der augsburger ersparen ich hätte
eine frage noch mal zum shutdown auf
denen sie eingangs zu sprechen gekommen
waren
sie hatten ja vor nicht allzu langer
zeit gesagt dass es aus der damaligen
sicht eigentlich nicht hätte zum
schließen zum beispiel von frisiersalons
hätte kommen müssen passiert genau wider
dass die schulen sollten so lange wie
möglich offen bleiben sie haben häufiger
betont die schulen sind kein infektions
treiber nun passiert genau das werden
jetzt eigentlich teilweise bereiche in
haftung genommen die eigentlich kein
infektions treiber sind warum kommt es
dann zu dieser harten reaktion
die frage ist eher andersrum wenn alle
bereiche keine infektionsträger wären
hätten wir keine infektion an der stelle
natürlich ist immer die frage wie groß
ist das risiko von infektionen das ist
ja auch die diskussion die ich mit
gastronomen und anderen führe die
natürlich richtigerweise darauf
hinweisen dass die gute hygiene konzepte
haben und zum teil auch viel investiert
haben in diese ideen konzepte und
schutzkonzepte aber das beste konzept
bringt es nicht auf null
in dem moment wo sich menschen begegnen
entsteht das risiko bei einem virus das
sich eben bei menschlichen begegnungen
überträgt dass es zur infektion kommt
wir können das risiko immer nur weiter
minimieren und auch in schulen und kitas
ist das risiko nicht bei null und
studien zeigen dass es möglicherweise
bei jüngeren unterdurchschnittlich ist
heißt es nicht dass es bei null ist
gerade weil er wieder die fünfjährigen
altersgruppen ansprach bei denen wir die
inzidenz beobachten gerade so ab 14.15
in den fünf altersgruppen bis 15 bis 20
20 25 bis 30 ist neben den besonders
alten der zweite bereich wo wir
besonders viele infektionen haben und
deswegen kitas und schulen so lange als
möglich auf aber eben so lange als
möglich und in der momentanen lage mit
dem infektionsgeschehen der hohen
incidents der dynamik die wir haben ist
jetzt eben sozusagen der punkt erreicht
wo es ihm nicht mehr möglich war ohne
die dinge auch vernünftig in den griff
zu bekommen und zu einzelhandel und
friseur
im rückblick war es wahrscheinlich im
frühjahr war es ja eine andere lage
manchmal genau nehmen sind wir gerade in
einer schwierigeren lage als wird im
frühjahr gewesen waren gibt ja viele die
sagen das können die virologen und die
epidemiologen besser sagen dass das
nicht selten so ist das die zweite welle
heftiger wird als die erste was glaube
ich nicht nur mit dem virus zu tun hat
sondern einfach mit der einstellung von
uns allen
aus den erfahrungen der ersten ersten
welle
aber wenn es aktuell um einzelhandel und
friseure geht
wissen sie das risiko ist nicht
entstanden im schuhgeschäft mit 20
quadratmeter pro 20 quadratmeter ein
kunde das risiko ist nicht zuletzt
entstanden wenn sie einfach in die
straßen schauen auf dem weg dahin in den
großen shopping malls in allen bereichen
drumherum gerade auch in einem monat
wieder im dezember monat der ja einer
daneben auch ist da besonders handel
shopping in anspruch genommen wird und
deswegen sind wir eben nicht weil ein
bereich besonders und alleine der
infektions treiber ist sondern weil wir
insgesamt in der gesellschaft in einem
umfang wieder infektionsgeschehen
gesehen haben dass uns hat aus meiner
sicht berechtigterweise vermuten lassen
dass wir in zwei vier wochen noch in
ganz anderen situationen sind jetzt zu
dieser entscheidung zu kommen
und in so einer lage zu sagen nur damit
ich am ersten september mit einer
aussage in bottrop auf dem marktplatz
mal recht gehabt hat darf jetzt aber
bitte nichts passieren finde ich keine
voran
deutliche politik da muss ich eben
akzeptieren dass ich damit meine
einschätzung ende hätte lieber richtig
gelegen ohne zweifel eine frage
ähnliche aspekt sascha meyer dpa fragt
die fußball-bundesliga und andere und
anderer profi sport soll nun anders als
im ersten doktor weiterlaufen ist das
vertretbar und das richtige signal auch
mit den nötigen vielen tests den ford
habe schreibt danach doch steht da ein
minister sparen steht also zum ersten
also die frage der dazu nötigen tests
ist schon seit längerem gar nicht mehr
das thema instruments um die
schnelltests geht da ist die
verfügbarkeit sehr sehr hoch
mittlerweile
und auch bei den pcr kapazitäten haben
wir mittlerweile die dinge wieder in
einer gut handelbaren größenordnung ohne
zuschauer
die entsprechenden profisport der
berufsausübung ist ein teil muss man
immer wieder dazu sagen kann man immer
darüber reden ob das jetzt da gibt es
doch nicht ganz unterschiedliche
einschätzungen der gesellschaft die
einen sagen es zumindest was was es dann
doch auch gibt mit dem man sich mal
jenseits von corona beschäftigen kann
die anderen sagen ist aber jetzt als
symbol vielleicht das falsche für das
infektionsgeschehen ist jetzt die frage
ob in deutschland am wochenende in
verschiedenen stadien gespielt wird oder
nicht eine größenordnung aber sage ich
jetzt mal die aussage mit der der mann
innsbruck mit dem test und
schutzkonzepte umgehen kann
die frage wie das gesellschaftliche
eingeordnet wird es glaube ich ganz
unterschiedlich das ist vielleicht sogar
eine 50 50 so hat das sage ich als
jemand jetzt nicht per se ein
ausgewiesener fußball fan ist aber
andersrum stellt schon fest dass das für
viele halt auch wichtig ist dass noch
ein paar dinge jenseits von kona da sind
wenn das geht ohne resi oder minimierten
risi absolut minimierten risiken und
sehr kleine zahl von beteiligten in
einem großen stadion dann ist das
vielleicht außerdem soll bald
winterpause da oder nicht
da finde ich jetzt auch noch gefragt wie
wir heute letzte frage geht an die von
uns aus gesehen rechten seite rtl n-tv
entspannt ganz wichtige meldung von der
dpa gerade bekommen hat dass die ehemals
bestätigt gegen würde presse agentur
dass ein investor zum 23.12 zugelassen
werden wird oder man geht nach wie vor
vom 29 12 10 ausdrücklichen tourist hat
und nicht einmal für sich ihre bewertung
dieses und diese zahl ist wichtig für
viele menschen denke ich mal und meine
eigentliche frage war damals der koran
ab da gab es einen eindringlichen appell
und besser die darüber liegen oder
janssens dieser endlich mal schärfer zu
stellen also wie sie auch in südkorea
beispielsweise funktioniert dass man
eben nicht unter die möglichkeit gibt
damit auch infektionsketten wirksam zu
unterbinden nachzuverfolgen
da wollte ich sie doch mal fragen der
minister ob sie da auch noch mal
handlungsbedarf sehen und vielleicht
druck ausüben möchten und auch
widerwillig frage ob sie sich das
wünschen würden dass dieser app besser
funktioniert als ist momentan tut also
ich kenne jetzt die meldung nicht so
sind kann ich sie jetzt nicht
kommentieren ich hatte nur die meldung
vor hingesehen und die bestätigung die
es aus brüssel gegeben hat wir werden
das so da somit mit umgehen müssen
ich jedenfalls werde weiterhin so oder
so für ein gründliches aber auch zügiges
zulassungsverfahren was eben auch im
interesse der europäischen union und der
akzeptanz für alles was wir tun
gemeinsam ist wenn das eben auch
begründet nachvollziehbar ein
gründliches aber auch schnellstmögliches
zulassungsverfahren ist und ansonsten da
ich versuche so wenig wie möglich auf
mein handy zu schauen während ich bei
ihnen in der pressekonferenz bin kann
ich jetzt wieder so rum noch so rum
bestätigen oder nicht bestätigen das
muss ich mir erst anschauen das zweite
wahl
die gründer waren app wir haben ja
letzte woche wie die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz ist
vereinbart hat auch eine runde karten
den ministerpräsidenten vertretern der
länder mit den
entwicklern und die bundesregierung dem
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten übrigens
und dem bse für die sicherheit in der
informationstechnologie und hatten einen
guten konstruktiven austausch aber
miteinander erörtert wo auch unter unser
prämisse von datensparsamkeit und
freiwilligkeit ist eben weitere
verbesserungsmöglichkeiten gibt
freiwillige symptomen oder kontakt
tagebücher zum beispiel die wir auch in
der entwicklung sind und haben das
gleichzeitig aber das also ich wissen
südkorea als beispiel verstehe ich ja
manchmal aber da wird bis hin zu
kreditkarten abrechnung oder
gesichtserkennung in teilen das ganze
verfolgt ich bin nicht sicher ob wenn
man mal die überschriften verlassen wenn
man wirklich hineingehen denn das was es
bedeutet einen anderen ansatz zu haben
bei der krone waren app nicht nur die
gleichen sondern vielleicht sogar
dieselben die jetzt sagen was ist denn
mit diesen datenschutz dann die debatte
genau andersrum führen würden nämlich
über die frage auf was man denn noch
alles zugreifen will um damit umzugehen
und das ist eine 50 weise nicht nehmen
das war im bekanntenkreis aber das
zeigen auch die umfragen ist ein 50/50
sache viele sagen intuitiv beim
datenschutz müsste denn da immer so
rigoros sein könnte nicht mehr
und mindestens so viele sagen wenn er
mehr macht ist diese app von meinem
handy verschwunden
und wenn ich dann höre verpflichtend die
app in seinem immer das heissen
verpflichtend ich kann noch nicht per
gesetz sagen jeder muss auf seinem handy
diese app haben und schon gar nicht kann
nichts kontrollieren wird schon gar
nicht kann ich kontrollieren ob jeder
seinen bluetooth immer an hat also ich
frage mich immer was dann aus den
überschriften so folgt an der stelle
und deswegen ist das konzept das wir
haben freiwillig daten sparsam und
gleichzeitig immer weiter entwickelt aus
dem was wir lernen denn dem angebot in
den möglichkeiten in der technik die
dahinter steckt aus meiner sicht das
wenige das am meisten erfolg verspricht
weil es eben weil es eben auch die
höchste akzeptanz hat mitten in dieser
pandemie eine kontroverse debatte die
wehr kontrovers da bin ich sehr sicher
über so eine frage zu führen ist nicht
das was zusammenhalt
deswegen verbessern wir die app im
zusammenspiel von bund und ländern und
allen die gute ideen haben immer weiter
aber bleiben bei unseren prinzipien
ja ich kann da auch nicht viel zufügen
ich möchte nur noch mal etwas
prinzipielles sagen wir haben eine menge
verschiedene werkzeuge und ich fand eben
auch die aussage von 40 ganz interessant
man bietet tests andern glauben manche
menschen jetzt bin ich frei getestet
jetzt bin ich negativ sind alles
verschiedene werkzeuge die alle mit sinn
und verstand eingesetzt werden müssen
der grundsatz wie wahr diese pandemie
bekämpfen ist dass wir unsere kontakte
einschränken ja dass wir möglichst wenig
weiter tragen dass wir wenig angesteckt
werden
und alle diese werkzeuge die wir haben
seines tools in den gesundheitsämtern
seines tests die wir einsetzen um zu
schauen dass jene konzepte stimmen all
das im gemeinsamen zusammenspiel wird
nur die die wende bringen jedes einzelne
dieser tools hat eine bestimmte
bedeutung aber es hängt vom verhalten
von uns als aller aller wichtigste ist
dass wir diese pandemie beherrschen ja
insofern arbeiten wir in der kroner
vanek mit mit vielen zusammen entwickeln
wir die immer weiter aber es gibt eine
reihe von anderen dingen ich sag mal ist
bleibt wie der grundsatz ist wir müssen
uns unsere kontakte soweit wie möglich
runter drehen und aufs gründen
notwendigste beschränken das ist das
ziel
und alle die anderen dingen helfen uns
dabei es sind hilfsmittel aber sie
ändern nicht die problematik das muss
wirklich jedem einsichtig sein
ich habe letztens mit einem gesprochenen
der dachte zum beispiel der im stall ist
da das problem ist gelöst
das ist tatsächlich war aber erst wenn
wir geimpft werden
ja das heißt also diese psychologie
hinter manchen dingen muss man schon
durch denken das ist wie eine formel 1
fahrer da führt und sieht das ziel und
fährt rechts ran parkt sagt auch da ist
ja das ziel ich habe gewonnen
wir müssen eben leider auch wenn
bestimmte mittel da sind die wir nutzen
und zwar intelligent nutzen sollten
müssten die grundsätze trotzdem war ich
denke das ist das ziel für uns dann all
der diskussion
danke damit sind wir am ende keine frage
hoffentlich offenen danke ihnen fürs
kommen danke vor allen dingen auch
unseren gästen fürs kommen